roll-call calm Thank You charlie thank
you we are joined here this morning by
longtime political reporter and author
Lou cannon wrote for a number of years
and covered the Reagan White House in
your new book is Reagan's disciple
george w bush's troubled quest for a
presidential legacy you wrote this with
your son Carl cannon who covers the
White House now you've written a number
of books about Ronald Reagan what
motivated this one well what what
motivated it I think most of all was
that George W Bush had compared himself
on his and his people had compared
themselves to Reagan as if he were going
to be a Minh other-- Reagan rather than
following in the footsteps of his father
and then in in March of 2003 I think it
was there was a I'm sorry in January
there was a story in New York Times
called Reagan's son it was written by
Bill Keller who was then the editor of
the magazine and was now the editor of
the newspaper and Bill quoted a number
of Reagan people and bush people to the
to the effect that that that Reagan that
the George W Bush was really trying
trying to be like Reagan now this was
seventeen this was I don't know seven a
couple of months before the Iraq war and
so Carl and I decided to sort of play
this out we gave we gave a speech at
Stanford where we both were under the
auspices of the Hoover Institution and
the speech was called the tale of two
presidents and it so happened that the
speech was given to to a mixed audience
of the Hoover people which tend to be
conservative in the Stanford alumni
which tend to be liberal not it's not
total in either case but that's and they
both seem to like it so we thought well
maybe we
turn this into a book and it was the
whatever else happens I'd say it's a
rewarding book for me because it was it
was really it was really fun to do it
for Carl first time you wrote a book
with your son the first time I've
written a book with anybody I just I
usually write my books myself you um
wrote an op-ed ahead of the release of
this book in The Washington Post a
couple of weeks ago the headline read
he's no Reagan but on some things he's
close and from that that piece in 2008
Republicans seeking to succeed George HW
Bush's son in office are not gunning for
a third George W Bush term more like a
fourth Reagan term and although it may
be a fool's errand to already assign the
current president his ultimate place in
the pantheon of presidents we believe
that George W Bush can be meaningfully
compared to Ronald Reagan is that
domestically internationally well I
think he can be compared it's both but I
think the domestically it's it's more of
a comparison and internationally it's
more of a contrast domestically george w
bush is has certainly followed reagan's
path on judicial appointments obviously
the Supreme Court appointments but but
all levels of the federal judiciary by
the time he leaves office he will have
appointed like three-fourths of the
federal between two thirds and
three-fourths of the federal judiciary
and and and those are appointments and
that are going to resonate I mean
they're they're going to have an impact
people people who say that George Bush
is gone he's gone are not paying
attention to to the Supreme Court legacy
particularly and I think that Bush
arguably learned from both Reagan and
his father he didn't want to appoint
somebody like David Souter who turned
out to be a fairly there both justice
and nothing was and he didn't want
another debacle like bob bork who was
highly qualified but but couldn't get
through the senate so he got two people
who both were were able to get confirmed
and who followed conservative principles
and then if you go to the tax cuts I
think I think it's fair to say there are
some differences in the tax policy but
but in by and large of Bush tax cuts who
are patterned after the Reagan tax cuts
but then if you go abroad and I we argue
and we argue it closely in this book we
don't just desert it that that Ronald
Reagan would would not we believe would
not have gone to war in Iraq and if he
had gone to war in Iraq we believe he
would not have gone committed troops to
a long war in Iraq if you look at Ronald
Reagan's record you see that the only
the really sort of catastrophe abroad
that happens on his watch of his
killings of the 240 some US servicemen
most of the Marines in this barracks
bunker in the gay route in 19 October
1983 the first of all the Marines
weren't there to promote democracy or
navin eight-hour nation-building they
were there as part of a multinational
force in and and there were the French
who were a big part of that force they
lost 75 or so paratroopers the same for
the same day the this was a terrorist
attack designed to drive to drive
Western forces out of Lebanon and it did
and American troops were gone within
three months four months but on other
issues and we examine each one of them
in this book Reagan was very careful
about sending troops US troops into
harm's way he opposed for instance the
the forced forcible removal of Noriega
of going into Panama with first Bush did
he said that we quote from the minutes
of the of the of the cabinet meetings he
takes on on his own cabinet and Bush and
Reagan says we're gonna lose lives we're
gonna cause a lot of civilian casualties
we're going to be looked upon as the
colossus of the of the north all things
it was actually predictive of the
reaction that
and when we did go into Panama so we
what we assert that Ronald Reagan
despite his militants in standing up to
the Soviets and everything was extremely
reluctant to involve American troops in
in any kind of prolonged combat anywhere
in the world and so we we think that
their Iraq the Iraq war would not have
been part of a Ronald Reagan as long as
you cover Ronald Reagan seemed like all
my life I covered him about 3035 years
off and on III I was was the in
sacre-coeur him in in his campaign for
governor of California in 1966 in his
first term as governor I was the San
Jose Mercury Sacramento correspondent
then later for the Washington Post
you know I picked him up and covered his
campaign against President Ford in 76
and I was the White House correspondent
for the for the March to post throughout
his presidency and I've written five
books about him so I've covered a
covered him a very long time so lots to
talk about we'll open up our phone lines
for viewers questions for mr. cannon
about his book about Ronald Reagan and
the bush legacy Reagan's disciple is the
name of the book the phone numbers 202
seven thirty seven zero zero zero one
for Republicans Democrats 202 seven
three seven zero zero zero two and
independence six to eight to oh two six
two eight zero two zero five and I think
we have a call waiting from Memphis a
Democratic caller go ahead Memphis yes
good morning good morning I just wanted
to make a serious comment here and that
is what I find deeply disturbing and I'd
like to you know all of the
Conservatives and the Republicans and
those in Congress or the Center for that
matter to listen to this and really take
this to heart but what I find deeply
disturbing is this fairy tale romance
with Ronald Reagan by conservatives
let us not forget his staunch support
for apartheid South Africa under the
regime of you know PW Botha where they
were shooting young African kids as dogs
in the streets and his deep vitriol
towards American unions and the right to
organize know what I say is this it's
not to take away from for from many of
the economic changes that he made in the
country or the fact that as Barack Obama
puts that he was a transformative figure
what I find very disturbing in my
measure of a great man or a woman for
that matter is during those quiet
moments in his or her life where they
make serious decisions to either change
this world for the good or to change it
towards a path of wickedness and he
chose the path of wickedness not to
mention the fact that his his penchant
towards apparently you know on many
statements people have said he's made
racist statements about blacks and
others in this country so this romance
romantic love affair that that these
conservatives have with this to be
honest with you a low dog I find quite
disturbing and excuse my language but
that's exactly what he was Thank You
Memphis talked about in a moment we'll
ask you about the the importance of the
mantle of Ronald Reagan for Republicans
but likewise it as you heard from the
caller it is it's the opposite with
Democrats in fact that Barack Obama
gotten a little bit of hot water with
his party or some recent comments that
he made about Ronald Reagan and ideas
well it's the opposite with some
Democrats Ronald Reagan got 20% of the
Democratic vote when he was reelected by
a landslide in 84 I think that's a
record it's very unusual that any
president gets 20% of the vote of the
opposite party and and and while there
is a sort of iconography if one wants to
call it that about Reagan among among
conservatives particularly there's
also a sort of a demonology which the
last caller reflected which includes in
both on both streams of this lots of
things that are fictional and never
happened Ronald Reagan was not a racist
and you can say he's a racist 87 times
if you want to believe that but it
doesn't make it true
Ronald Reagan certainly had a backward
attitude in my view toward South Africa
but it's also true that under his
presidency he worked out a constructive
arrangement thanks to the good people
that he had in the State Department that
put South Africa on the path to
democracy so there's a lot of things
that get repeated on both sides of this
that if you if you look at the facts
which is all what I took what I try to
do I'm neither
I'm not Reagan's cheerleader and I'm not
he's apologized and I and I criticize
him many times as anybody who's read any
of my books no but but he had a good
heart and he wanted to do the right
thing and people who who refused to
acknowledge that are are refusing to
understand him just as the people who
say that he could walk on water and his
presidency was a series of unmitigated
times they're not are not looking at
history either let's hear another caller
we go to Lake Geneva Wisconsin a
Republican caller good morning yeah how
come you don't have a single Republican
on your show this morning my first
question and your other question sir
well I'd like that question answered
first we have we have Republicans and
Democrats every day we don't always
evenly divide them but today we have a
couple of Democratic representatives
some days we have equal amount of
Republicans you have a question for mr.
cannon you've got four Democrats
including mr. cannon they're not a
democratic in your past books you've
criticized bragging to the nth degree so
we most your critics will probably
consider you're you you're all just for
the Democrats probably consider you
liberal anyway my question to you is uh
can you uh this last caller that called
in would I got a question about him
because
didn't mr. Reagan increase a lot of the
age of the Africa to Africa and raise
raise of a question about prosecution of
Africans by apartheid so to speak so
could you answer that what was it about
Reagan that that that folks have such an
allegiance to him I don't know I was
trying I want to try to answer the
caller's question I don't know about
it's been a long time since I've been
golfing liberal it's a I don't know
about aid to Africa I don't I don't
claim to have a encyclopedic knowledge
of everything that went on the Reagan
administration but but there was a
policy called constructive engagement by
which the Reagan and his foreign policy
team and I think a present both gets
deserves the blame and the credit for
what what his team does because
presidents themselves focused on a few
things in Africa was never never Ronald
Reagan's focus it was called
constructive engagement and it worked
pretty well in Africa the the idea was
that that you you would try to to stop
the various regimes from fighting each
other and that you would try to assist
the progress for a democracy I think
that I think that Africa tends to be in
the back burner for America the United
States of America and for presidents of
both parties and unfortunately so but I
don't think that Reagan right I think
that what Reagan did do in that area was
was was moderately helpful rather than
than moderately harmful i bill I didn't
answer your question you what you asked
me a question but big question was the
why folks feel such an allegiance to him
particularly Republicans but he also
created a class of voter called Reagan
Democrats I think the thing with there's
sort of two things with Reagan about
that one is that Reagan himself was an
appealing character he's an appeal
appealing political personality they
come along
they're not they're not Legion though
you know FDR JFK Reagan some people felt
that way about Bill Clinton but in
Reagan's case the Republican Party and
the conservative movement were really
down when he came along this country was
largely a democratic country and yeah
there were a couple of Republican
presidents Eisenhower was so different
he was elect he was a general you know
he was like he was the general of the
people and he didn't really seemed a lot
of Republicans like a Republican Nixon
who had a promising start and did some
good things left office in disgrace so
there really wasn't any you know Ford
wasn't able to get elected so there
wasn't any Republican success and there
certainly wasn't any conservative
success Reagan took conservative ideas
and that's what Obama recognized and I
don't know whether it probably didn't
help Obama in politics but I do it's
another sign that Obama is paying
attention to what's what's going on in
this country and and and and he put
conservative ideas in a way that were
palatable to ordinary people and he was
a success and why are these people
comparing themselves to Reagan
well Reagan is a is a a guy who won a 49
state landslide reelection he left
office he's approval ratings were in the
60s George Bush has been down around 30%
for a long time so you're naturally if
you want to get elected president you're
not going to be comparing yourself to
the to the unpopular figure but to the
popular one we are talking about
lukannon spoke with his son Carl cannon
Reagan's disciple and taking your phone
calls your thoughts on Ronald Reagan on
the book the book in the relation to
relationship to President Bush let's go
to our independence line and
winston-salem
go ahead morning good morning yes I was
watching and then the discussion went
into Africa and Nelson Mandela in South
Africa I just want to say that I'm
Jamaican and Jamaica played a big part
in the release of death Mandela and the
Jamaica was the first country that he
visited when he was released from jail
also the fact that
politics crept into it about Ronald
Reagan got 20% of the Democratic vote
back then and then the president so far
have not paid much attention to the to
Africa itself well I would say that I'm
I would hope that and I believe that if
this time around Barack Obama is going
to get 20 percent of the Republican
votes and because he has African roots
then Africa will definitely be attended
to
I'm sorry had to have to twist away from
the book for the politics crept in so
I've chosen that No thank you mr. winter
: Oh we'll be talking about Africa
policy in our next segment with Donald
Payne of New Jersey who's head of the
Subcommittee on Africa you write a
little bit in the book about why
conservatives have soured on george w
bush what's the biggest reason the the
biggest reason originally was the war
there one of the things that happened in
this country after the end of the Cold
War which Ronald Reagan certainly
contributed to ending was that the great
adversary of the United States the
Soviet Union was no longer first it was
no longer power and then it was no
longer it was no longer there and there
are a lot of different countervailing
tendencies in the conservative movement
there are tendencies that are have been
described as isolationist a nationalist
there are lots of people who don't there
there is a concern about American
imperialism at the fringes of American
politics both by the left and by the
right and I I think that Republicans did
not feel even Republicans who felt that
work didn't feel quite free to assert
that view as long as the Soviet Union's
out there with you know all thousands of
missiles you know pointed at us and not
in ours at them but after the collapse
of the of the Soviet Union that strain
of American conservatism
a certain asserted itself so so there
were a lot of conservatives who never
really were on board for this war in
Iraq to begin with and then and then
there's all other sorts of things that
come into play the Army is overstrained
people who believe that it's the as I do
that the America that maintaining the
American American military in some kind
of aroma around the world I mean what do
you do if there's a crisis somewhere
else you know we're we're really under
strained in in in in Iraq but it wasn't
just Iraq and that's the thing if I I
think if the Iraq war had had ended
smoothly and swiftly as Bush could had
believed obviously that it would it
would have taken longer for these these
these divisions to emerge but it's also
that that what the National Review
called big government conservatism the
Republicans came into power and the 90s
in Congress and Bush's elected president
and things are supposed to change and
they don't change there's all these
earmarks there's all these these you
know a bloated farm bill you know in
balanced budgets bush
Kerry said some things in last elections
that I would certainly think were were
inaccurate but one thing he said that
was completely accurate was that Bush
had an veto any bill now Bush's lately
in the last six months or a year trying
to get back into in the graces of
conservatives you point out also that
Ronald Reagan hadn't vetoed too many
domestic bills no but but but but but
the difference is this when Ronald
Reagan was governor I mean when I was
governor - but when he was president he
had a Democratic Congress the entire
time Reagan was fighting to get peel off
enough Democrats which he did that he
could pass tax cutting measures and pass
pass his budget but he was never in a
position where he was able to say
Congress you can you can follow my
economic policies and will you know
we'll go forward together
was in that position Bush had a
Republican Congress and and the
Republican Congress did not did not
deliver on Republican promises and that
has soured a lot of concern let's let
our callers weigh in on some thoughts on
mr. Reagan mr. cannons book go ahead
Newark New Jersey on our Democrats line
hi good morning I'm a first-time call a
little nervous so please be patient with
me uh but I am I just can't understand
what happened to Americans I believe
Americans have become more Democrat and
Republicans that forgot to be American I
cannot understand how we could sit here
and glorify Ronald Reagan when Ronald
Reagan and my estimation has made this
world a more dangerous place the
collapse of the Soviet Union did not
make Russia a safer place they still
have all those nuclear weapons and then
you get the country like that and you
break it financially I'm looking for I
wouldn't be surprised at any day to see
those nuclear weapons out on the open
market let's stand let's stay in New
Jersey get another caller a Republican
here from Trenton hi all right good
morning good morning thank you for
taking my call it's uh it's really great
to have someone available dancer
authoritative Lee a question about both
Reagan and Bush first about I consider
Bush and Reagan the only to quote
conservative presidents and first I'd
like to point out that conservatives are
like unicorns and dragons they simply
don't exist anymore
Rush Limbaugh calls Tom DeLay Newt
Gingrich the two top conservatives the
what call them not conservatives anymore
and then the second conservative
president just proposed the largest
budget ever three trillion dollars so
the question I have about these two
conservative presidents has to do with
their background as governors and then
the rise to the White House and then
once they got there what happened thank
you for your call Trenton compared
President Bush and the is rise in Texas
with with Ronald Reagan and the how
important is it that both of them were
Westerners well
George will said once that Americans are
conservative and what they want to
conserve is the New Deal and and that
that's clearly was the case with Ronald
Reagan and we know a lot more about
about Reagan now from those Diaries of
his and Reagan consistently he wouldn't
really answer the question when he was
president but what he what he what he
wanted to do was conserve the New Deal
but he didn't want to conserve the Great
Society I mean he was and and I think
that there are a lot of things built
into our system in terms of the
so-called entitlement program Social
Security Medicare a lot of things that
we we take for granted that overwhelming
numbers of Americans whether they're
conservatives or liberals or as our
moderates or whether independent and as
I am or a Democrat or a Republican want
so you're not gonna get some kind of
pure conservatism I bet we could safely
predict that every budget in the next
four years is going to be the largest
budget and that's going to be true
whether we have a Republican or a
Democrat in the White House I think that
Bush and Reagan like well presidents
were shaped somewhat by their experience
and they were certainly shaped by their
experiences as governor and I don't know
that we do enough of this in the book
all we do a little bit on it but in some
ways that helped Reagan more than it
helped Bush and here's why not because
of any deficiency or greatness of either
of them but but California has a modern
political system when Reagan was
governor it has a very developed
bureaucracy when Reagan was governor it
had a political system that replicated
the system that he would face in
Washington powerful Democratic Speaker a
state Senate that was it could go either
way and that you had to make alliances
in a you know a bureaucracy that got
very heavily involved and so it was a
great it was a great training ground in
bud in Texas
again through no fault of Busch the
Texas governor is deliberately created
as a weak executive what he can most
mostly do in is by consensus and getting
people together and if you look at what
george w bush tried to do before before
9/11 before before the world changed No
Child Left Behind he tried to govern he
tried to govern initially the way he had
governed in Texas it might have worked
had there not had had we not had 911 and
the and the intrusion of the outer world
and into America let's get a caller from
Westchester Westchester County New York
and independent caller good morning good
morning I wanted to follow up on a
gentleman who called earlier and called
a fairy tale of Ronald Reagan by most
conversations in American society today
I would say that people would say Reagan
and Bush were the least intelligent the
least inform the least visionary
presidents we've had where is this aura
coming from that they're great leaders
because the country's always been left
worse off after their presidencies can
you comment on that
Thank You New York well it the the
default position in American politics
for Republicans when they don't know
what to say is they they call the they
call a Democrat or a liberal and the
default position for Democrats when they
don't want to know what to say or bother
to read and examine the facts is they
they call the Republican presidents
stupid so so that happened with
Eisenhower it happened with it happened
but it didn't happen to it Nixon but it
happened with Ford it happened with
Reagan and happened with George W Bush
in one of my books I examine the
question of Reagan's intelligence and
and I do it using a kind of a standard
text frames of mind the theory of
multiple intelligences by Howard Gardner
and Reagan is an intelligent person and
one of the reasons that Reagan got to be
one of the reasons the regen got to be
president is that is that he was
underestimated and he encouraged his
underestimation it his candle power was
underestimated at every turn
how did that begin I think in Reagan's
case it's because he was an actor and
for many people actor was then and now
is synonym for airhead well we've got a
lot of actors that that are you know we
got a lot of actors it that are you know
a lot brighter than I am you know and
and III think that sort of persist you
know you got that label I think in a
curious way this is go happen with Bush
in a curious way it gets pushed off the
hook
because if if the guy is stupid
then then obviously it's gonna make bad
decisions right he's gonna but but the
truth is they're not these guys are not
stupid you don't get to be a present in
the United States if you're stupid and
and and they should be held accountable
for their actions and it doesn't get you
anywhere it doesn't really get you
anywhere to talk about a president a
president in those terms I think the
question with George W Bush I don't know
that my son I ride it's not a lot of
these programs with me and I wish were
here this morning I don't think bushes
is stupid at all but I think he's
somewhat tone-deaf I think he doesn't he
doesn't quite hear hear
resonant what is is happening and I
don't think he was he realized how
quickly quickly public opinion in this
country would turn around when the Iraq
war proved to be a long difficult war
let's go back to our callers and I have
an email after that we're going to go to
a new iberia Louisiana and a Democrat
good morning good morning gentlemen I've
been watching this and it was just flat
against it some of the comments of the
guests there I'm looking at reg in the
city trying to preserve the New Deal
when actually he went right after Kinsey
and economics into the Friedman school
which was the keystone of the New Deal
so that is inherently false on his
foreign policy
now we had the iran-contra I remember
that which which was point on today hide
in facts and presidential of Rights and
so forth to hide crimes that he
committed it's what George Bush is doing
what they've done pretty much during all
the Republican administrations he's also
responsible for a loss of our rights if
you looked at mr. international during
his administration we were considered a
police state because of all the rights
we lost on the war on drugs
and all this is all these things have
continually snowball all these years and
here is George Bush and here is America
it's a sad state of affairs and you can
lay on the foot of Republicans and I
think believe this gentleman has
obviously get up there and try to
rewrite history any reaction to that
well not really it's it's as anybody who
reads my my books knows what I try to do
is write history and I and I'm I'm quite
I'm quite hard on these guys in some
ways and I think I see their
achievements and I just think that III
wished in this country we could get
beyond the notion that one party is
wonderful and the other party is awful
because that kind of thinking doesn't
really get us anywhere well get a couple
more calls with Lou cannon we did get an
email I wanted to to point out to you a
writer says it's recently been suggested
that George HW Bush's presidency indeed
his entire career has been one of
opposition to the legacy of his father
how much of this psychological
psychological element do you ascribe to
his governing style I guess he's quoting
from the bush tragedy by Jacob Weisberg
well well I don't Karl did did most of
that part of the writing but we don't we
don't try to put we don't try to put
Bush on the couch I think that that
there are some there are some issues on
which Bush you don't need to go to to
psychoanalysis
we're Bush quite consciously try not to
repeat what he perceived as the mistakes
of his father and and one of those was
on taxes
you remember Bush said well you know
Bush senior said read my lips no no more
taxes now there's a huge historical
debate about that it was was Bush wrong
was Bush wrong to break his promise it
was he wrong to make his promise I'll
leave that to others but but it was
quite clear that this Bush did not want
to be in a position where he promised
tax cuts and then and then enacted tax
increases and the other example which I
alluded to earlier was David Souter
David Souter is an estimable human being
and and and probably a very good judge
but but the way we chose David Souter as
a country as the confirmed him is a
comment on on on on how polarized things
have become the reason that Souter was
principally chosen was that he had no he
had no written record like Robert Bork
he had no he had no he'd almost no paper
trail
and I guess I guess that I'd ask this
question I'd ask it for liberals that
are conservatives is that really what we
want do do are we really the point where
if you're if you have distinguished but
controversial writings as has worked in
that that disqualifies you from being a
Supreme Court justice if we've gonna
follow that principle aren't we gonna
wind up in some future time with with
nine non entities on the Supreme Court
and I think that that that that George W
Bush tried very he got involved he got
in turn he tried very hard not to do
that and he got to whether you agree
with them or not is a whole nother
question but he got two qualified people
in Roberts and and Alito but even here
even on this
there was a certain tone deafness and
you got that with Harriet Miers and the
Harriet Miers Fiasco it lasted was two
weeks there's a counter point pointing
her to the Supreme Court it lasted a few
weeks but it has sort of deprived I
think Bush of a much credit even among
conservative support for what he's done
in the Supreme Court because the Meyers
appointment was seen as is so
preposterous our times winding down so
we're gonna get one more caller here
Flint Michigan good morning you're on
the air
Republican live yes you can go ahead yes
I had a question for you you know Reagan
was really concerned about the human
rights issue over in China and I just
wonder what things have changed today
that that were ignoring the human rights
of Chinese people and we're doing all
those timers and trade and borrowing
money from them no what what what do you
think Ronald Reagan would say about the
things that were that are going on today
thanks thanks Lynn I'm glad we had that
question because Ronald Reagan was you
know he was very concerned about human
rights in a lot of places he gave
Mikhail Gorbachev the Soviet leader list
of imprisoned dissidents you know every
time they met I think that Ronald Reagan
spoke up when he was in China he tried
again and again they kept pressing this
speech that he was giving about human
rights
he finally they finally let him give it
in in in Shanghai but I I don't think
that in fairness that Ronald Reagan or
any other American leader democrat or
republican has the answer we want trade
with China we want the globalization
that this represents and at the same
time every American president has been a
President Clinton and and both President
Bush's and President Reagan have all
been upset with what with with with
China's refusal to recognize basic human
rights we don't have an answer the
answer the popular answer that if you
continue to trade with them and you
continue there they're going to become
more like us and and I don't see the
evidence that that that's true and it's
it's a it's a it's a very important
issue and it's
that that the next president whoever he
or she is and whatever and whatever
party he or she represents is going to
have to grapple with speaking of
potential presidents we'll wrap this up
the Conservative Political Action
Conference today in Washington hearing
from a number of Republican candidates
including John McCain who will carry
here on c-span radio and c-span three
live at 3:00 p.m. Eastern you're
speaking to that group what are you
going to talk about well I'm I hope I'm
going to talk about the book
I'm there with Carl and the it's a
discussion moderated by Robert Novak and
and I'm I'm hoping that the that the
audience will be will be interested in
in what we have to say about Reagan and
Bush I'm not perhaps they all perhaps
they'll have reservations about what we
have to say as much as your callers do
this morning well we wish you luck with
that
the book is Reagan's disciple george w
bush's troubled quest for presidential
legacy lukannon spent our gas t co-wrote
the book with his son Carl cannon thank
you for joining us thank you Bill
we're going to come back in just a
moment with representative Donald Payne
of New Jersey to talk about Kenya the
hearings held yesterday Africa policy
and more we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]